hey guys so I thought it would be time
for another vlog I haven't done one of
these for a little while but I'm going
to try it the effort to do these more
regularly but make them shorter in this
one I thought I talked about some really
exciting developments they've been
happening in my PhD recently so for
those of you who are new here my PhD is
on climate physics and more specifically
it's about trying to understand how
weather that happens in the middle and
sphere affects the weather at the
surface now there's old video which I'll
put up there which describes basically
what I'm doing but I'm a really cool
breakthrough recently actually I suppose
- so to understand what the first
breakthrough has been about yeah I need
to talk a little bit more about exactly
what it is that I do so what I'm working
on is what's called a dynamical model of
coupling between the stress if you in
the troposphere what that means is that
I'm looking at how for a given change in
the atmosphere above the pole what
happens to the rest of the atmospheric
column of air stretching from the
surface right over to the top down so if
well since of the stratosphere what
happens in that calm and how those
changes they're induced by that initial
change evolve over time now the key
thing that I've been working on with
this dynamical theory is hmm think of it
like this imagine that you have the
Arctic Circle right which is about 65
degrees north and you treat that as a
little circle on the face of the earth
and you raise a wall a huge huge
Plexiglas wall from the ground right
there to the top of the stratosphere
so you're controlling the amount of air
that can get in or out of that boundary
over 65 north and if it's a completely
solid Plexiglas wall no air gets in
around what I've been looking at
basically is imagining that that wall
has a different permeability at
different heights and that if you squish
the atmosphere within the polar circle
within the Arctic Circle and you say put
a bit more mass over the top of that
wall you're gonna squish the air that's
in side through the wall and you're
gonna cause temperature noise and
pressure anomalies but if the wall is
permeable or slightly permeable then
some of the air will flow
from doing that basically what I've been
looking at is understanding in the real
atmosphere how permeable the wall is a
different ice now I've been doing this
for quite some time and I was getting
anywhere I just was stumbling over basic
things and it didn't seem to be making
any sense because all the physics are
plug into my code was completely right
but it was spitting out nonsense and it
turned out the problem
as it always is with me was incredibly
stupid I've been programming my model
tell to analyze how air flowed in and
out of the atmosphere and to make a
prediction of stuff that goes on within
the polar region I've been telling it
that the atmosphere was 13 meters thick
instead of 30 kilometers thick it's a
simple mistake
I'd also point out that the ammeter
isn't actually 30 kilometers thick
that's basically 30 kilometers to the
need to up a point of the stratosphere
which is what I'm concerned with reading
the atmosphere is well it's actually
difficult to say where it stops it's
about Holland a hundred kilometers tall
is a simple mistake to make basicly I in
my head I was working units of
kilometers but in order for the physics
to what you have to do in SI unit so
everything has to be seconds kilograms
Newtons and meters not kilometers once I
make that change to my code everything
started making sense and it was amazing
because my PhD is now finally getting
somewhere it feels like so that first
bit having happened the second
breakthrough is a little bit more banal
really basically given that now I have
code which actually works and for the
physics which I put into it all produce
for a given squishing at the polar
column the Polka column of air in the
artists above the Arctic Circle what the
atmosphere below the squishing point if
you like is gonna do and how much of it
is gonna flow out and accordingly how
much pressure normally
different points the atmosphere you're
gonna have so you can never make a
prediction based on that of those duck
bit of physics that you put into the
model and because you've got a
prediction and you've got observed data
you can
how far from the truth your prediction
is and one spent an awful lot of time
doing recently is working a program
which basically does the physics works
have an eighth prediction and then
comparing that prediction to the
observed data now that's another break
free because what that allows you to do
is it gives you a quantifiable number
for how good your prediction is but
crucially why it allows me to do is to
say what well this bit of physics
produced a prediction that was a four on
the Simon Clark a fifth prediction
efficiency scale whereas this second bit
of physics produced a three so the bit
of physics that went into the prediction
the second time around were worse or
further from the truth than the physics
that went in the first time around so
you can do is you can iterate different
bits of science the put into the
computer model and then compare the
output of that model to reality and see
how far apart they are the further apart
they are the worse the physics and the
closer they are the closer you're
getting to the truth of how air flows in
and out of the polar regions now this
might sound unbelievably dull for some
of you but this cover stuff makes me
really excited Nina this is why I became
a PhD researcher because science like
this is awesome making incremental
improvements I'm doing that a lot sorry
I'm getting quite excited by well I'm
looking I'm wearing you make incremental
improvements to your understanding and I
you get the impression you're just
pushing the envelope of human knowledge
and your tiny little little section of
human knowledge of pushing it up bit
further than it was before
and it's an awesome awesome feeling you
know I am the first person to ever look
at this result because it's an
experiment I design myself I wrote all
the code I did all the analysis I know
what it means and now it's up to me to
try and translate that into both
scientific language to try and
communicate to the scientific community
or what it means and what it means for
understanding of the atmosphere but also
to you guys I'm just kicking up a little
bit sorry I realized that some of you
are gonna be here basically because you
followed me through other blogs like the
Oxbow project and some of you are gonna
be here because I do a PhD and you're
interested in it so let me know down
there in the comment section if you
found this interesting if you have any
questions about my PhD them far away and
I'll try my best to answer them
and yeah if you'd like to see more about
my PhD let me know because I will try
and do these loads more regularly with
updates on what I've been up to
I just hope my supervisor never finds
them because they're probably really
embarrassing in other non PhD news next
week I'm going to be going to an awesome
event in London I've been invited to the
creator studio like the Google
headquarters in Europe in London to go
to a production workshop for people who
make educational videos like this guy so
I'll hopefully be vlogging that
experience and taking you with me on one
show will be I'm so excited I'm so so
excited
and lastly back to PhD news this
December I will be going to a EGU 2015
which is the world's largest science
conference it's in San Francisco and yes
I'll be vlogging that experience and
that's going to be incredible I get to
throw on an a380 on the way out there
but also if you're watching this and
you're going to be at AG 2015 please
please comment below say hello we can
maybe organize like this if there's
loads of us though going because I
imagine there's quite the earth science
PhD - mmm well hopefully there's quite a
few as five species of watch this then
you know say hello and we can sort of
you know meet up when we're out there
that'd be cool thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time I basically
started sporting some people recently
and I realized that maybe you don't know
about these contact craters and I think
they're like the best things on YouTube
so you know let's share so I'm just
getting ready to go in with the tamarins
but I mean we're going in with these
piece of pipe Tamron
- we just found out well I just found
out but you can't take a baguette
because they are terrified of everything
that they can be bundled into